[Música]
parís junio de 2021 después de meses y
meses de privaciones la ciudad a casi
vuelto a la normalidad los teatros los
cines los espacios culturales renacen
los desfiles de moda despiertan por fin
un ambiente apagado en dior su directora
artística la británica keane jones
colaboró con el rapero estadounidense
travis scots a pesar del árido escenario
del desierto texano el ambiente para la
presentación de las colecciones de la
moda masculina primavera-verano 2022 es
festivo la vida vuelve a la normalidad
aquí pero también en los bares en las
salas de conciertos donde los cines es
un reencuentro volver y estar entre una
fantasía me encanta la moda como
fantasía pues ya no aguanto más no veo
la hora de volver a salir de gira se
siente muy bien estar juntos de nuevo
tenemos que cruzar los dedos para que
esto siga así para que dure
ésta continuó y salió así que crucemos
los dedos y los cactus y los hongos
gigantes y las flores fantasmagóricas
vestidos con prendas estructuradas
camisas pintadas a mano por el artista
neoyorquino george condo
yo voy jones
tiene un toque inglés en la moda
francesa y está bastante bien hecho
siempre tiene buenas colecciones y me
gustan mucho sus prendas
trabaja mucho con los materiales
es un personaje interesante que se
renueva constantemente su nivel gusta me
gustan los diseñadores que despiertan la
libido el deseo de los demás y siento
que eso es un motor el deseo me gustó
ver a estos chicos desfilando tan
tranquilos tan seguros de su silueta eso
hace que queramos salir así a las calles
de parís si el mundo dejó de soñar
propongamos fantasía con las prendas que
usamos
son fantasías excentricidad el viaje a
la imaginación la esencia de la moda el
joven diseñador antonio álvarez es un
apasionado de los deportes extremos
orgulloso de sus orígenes filipinos y
adora la libertad de viajar solo por el
mundo sino por todos los mundos
es muy importante animar los actuales a
viajar no sólo geográficamente sino
también sus ideas ser abiertos
eso es lo que intento hacer cada
temporada se trata de presentar a la
gente una nueva cultura un nuevo viaje
con esta positividad de este optimismo
con la idea de celebrar cada
individualidad
de la temporada desarrollamos estampados
propios con muchos colores eso es muy
importante para mí esta temporada
tuvimos amarillo azul naranja colores
arcoiris también son colores que me
hacen soñar
para mí esta temporada es como un viaje
a una isla paradisíaca de filipinas ese
era mi objetivo
hacerme soñar porque había mucha
frustración por no poder vernos salir
viajar así que intenté hacer eso a
través de la colección
cada conexión viajar por todo el mundo
acercarse a asia a china el dorado del
look
el diseñador parisino luego abriel noche
además de diseñar su propia colección
dirige el diseño de la marca china yue
wang cuál es su concepto cuando la ruta
de la seda se cruza con la ancestral
cual deia francesa me pareció una buena
manera de hablar de conexiones de viajes
y algo un poco positivo teniendo en
cuenta lo que estamos viviendo quiere
decirnos que por fin vamos a verlo y por
fin vamos a volver hacen el intercambio
entre china europa y el resto del mundo
que tal vez volvamos a viajar pronto
viaja en pantalón porque es la
especialidad de esta que decir entonces
de todas las 50 se construyeron en torno
a los pantalones por eso este tema
marino de la ruta de la seda con todos
estos pantalones marineros las copias
estos shows muy cortos que hacen
siluetas bastante cuadradas bastante
contemporáneas que muestran el puerto y
los pantalones son la pieza más técnica
la gente no se da cuenta necesariamente
hay mucho trabajo en una chaqueta pero
se debe dar mucho cuidado con el
pantalón otra actitud es reflexionar
sobre el mundo para el aniversario 18 de
su marca andrea cruz la papisa del up
cycling marussia rebeca presentó una
visión yo hay 18 jóvenes que representan
a andrea juegos así que hicimos una
película que habla en primera persona
soy andrea cruz tengo 18 años y así es
como veo el mundo y la moda hoy en día
yo vi
[Música]
pero entonces cómo vestirse simple jeans
y camisetas una christina personalizamos
nuestros jeans con mensajes utópicos y
políticos sobre el mundo de mañana y
rompimos nuestras camisetas para
expresar nuestra energía y nuestro deseo
de crear la forma de fabricar las
prendas o la energía y la diversión que
ponemos en ellos les dan un alma yo creo
que ahora la gente los consumidores se
dan cuenta de que es algo importante sé
que sus no pocos hicimos estos jeans con
un mensaje que es también el de fashion
revolutions es todo un movimiento de
moda y corresponsable en todo el mundo
soñamos con un mundo mejor así que
imprimimos el planeta imprimimos a
nuestras mujeres políticas e hicimos
buenos jeans un poco sexys igual que
llevamos pancartas en las
manifestaciones y ahora llevamos nuestro
mensaje en los links de jim
the new actual de lino o seda lo
importante ya no es el material sino el
mensaje la moda está cambiando sólo
puede anticipar lo mejor
[Música]